so none of this is actually dangerous
right here
none of this is dangerous I've done it
for years and I've only dropped a person
once a night was just due to this
jamendo shock
yeah and I'll lady come walking up but
she got the shock and her knees went out
I wonder are you okay so actually what's
happening when he does that bite my
right leg is actually the exit they've
got about a quarter million to a half a
million volts depending on the humidity
okay up here and I raised my body
voltage at high because I'm insulated
okay and then when I put out my hand and
touch you or drop by the elders I
approach you the potential
right - growls - ground through your
body right there red black so there's
like a little spark coming out of my
foot - you owe me that much gold again
doesn't even see the electron conveyor
belt okay picks up electrons down there
take them up there and accumulate them
until it accumulates a big charge and
then it dissipates okay this all happens
in microseconds okay and so it's also
micro amps so it's not dangerous but it
is up high and folding and so you get
all the fun of a high voltage